with over 75 million people playing it
warzone is one of the biggest games on
the planet right now
but the battle royale also has a
gigantic cheating problem that's existed
pretty much since
launch things have gotten so bad that
guys like shroud have quit playing the
game
outright but it seems like publisher
activision blizzard have
finally decided to do something about it
because they're reportedly suing the
[ __ ]
out of one of the game's biggest
cheating websites
all right guys so every wednesday at 1
pm eastern you can find us streaming our
talk show clouded over at twitch.tv
slash the score esports
and if you enjoy what we do here on
don't at me make sure you follow the
channel
and hit the notification button so you
know exactly when we go live
talking about some of the biggest
stories from esports and streaming
okay let's get back to the story it's no
secret that warzone has a giant cheating
problem i mean just tune in to any nick
merc stream
and you'll figure that out pretty quick
and it's your typical cheating [ __ ]
wall hacks aim locks no scoping some
unsuspecting player
from across the map
holy [ __ ]
oh never mind he's [ __ ] cheating done
and while sure it's got your tim the
tatmans and nadeshots of the world all
pissed off
it's even worse when it comes to guys
like nick merks or somebody like teepee
two dudes who regularly host giant war
zone tournaments
and complain about this issue constantly
so not only is this problem affecting
your favorite solo streamer it's
wreaking havoc on a competitive scene
that sprung up around
warzone
[ __ ] man bro
that was a good game dude you could
barely see us we're not even loading on
his screen
guys be sure to drop along oh whoa
hello
and it finally seems like publisher
activision blizzard and developer
infinity war
are deciding to do something about it as
they've reportedly filed a lawsuit
against one of the game's biggest
cheating websites now cxcheats.net which
is the cheating website in question it's
fairly standard you pay a fee and then
they give you access to a bunch of
cheating options
now i say reported lawsuit because
neither activision blizzard nor infinity
ward have made a public statement about
it
the way we know that a lawsuit might be
happening is because the cheating
website itself
announced it in the cheating website's
discord they posted this announcement on
august 27th
quote as some of you may know activision
publishing inc has filed a lawsuit
against cx cheats.net
and has made it clear to us that our
services violate their terms of use
as a result of our lawsuit with
activision we have agreed to cease
development and support
for all call of duty related products or
services sold through the site
these products will not be returning to
cx cheats in any form
you should also be aware that using
third-party tools in call of duty
may result in the suspension or banning
of your account by activision publishing
inc or the game's developers we
apologize for any pains we have caused
to the players of call of duty
end quote now the way they wrote this
announcement in a discord server makes
it seem like there's some mega
corporation that took like 72 hours
thoughtfully planning this [ __ ] thing
out it's very weird a lot of people
online noted that this in no way is
going to fix the problem but
finally something is being done now this
lawsuit comes after
months of people complaining about this
cheating problem while infinity ward
remained pretty quiet about it there was
a couple band waves here and there but
nothing that would actually put a stop
to this ramp and cheating
and the only other time that activision
blizzard or infinity ward said anything
about this prior to the lawsuit
was a statement that infinity ward made
on july 24th
and well it was laughable quote please
do not use
unauthorized third-party software to mod
or hack
this includes tools such as hex editors
that equip items you have not acquired
properly we
define this as cheating and there is no
place for that in our game
this is a bannable offense and you risk
losing your account
end quote so yeah they basically said
hey cheating's not nice
don't do it this first statement was
predictably meme don and the entire cod
scene took
shots at infinity ward for how much of a
non-answer this statement was
and it's easy to look at this lawsuit as
both a response to the community by
saying hey
we hear you while also recognizing that
it's going to take more than
ban waves to fix anything and while this
does appear to be a pretty
straightforward lawsuit the type of
thing that we've reported on in the past
there is a weird legal caveat to all of
this see cheating in warzone or
in any video game for that matter isn't
illegal as in it's not against the law
to cheat in a video game
so in order for activision blizzard to
go after these websites in court
they need to get a little creative as in
they basically have to sue for copyright
infringement which activision blizzard
has done in the past with overwatch
another one of their games that has a
massive cheating problem
see back in 2017 activision successfully
sued a cheating website for 8.6
million dollars after that website was
found guilty of 42
000 counts of copyright infringement in
that situation they
argued that the cheating website reverse
engineered and altered overwatch without
their permission
and according to multiple different
reports the cheating website in question
chose not to defend themselves in court
so in my mind either they were making
so much money they could take an 8
million loss and not even blank
or they just actually couldn't defend
themselves and decided not to show up
and that cheating website wasn't even
shut down they just couldn't offer their
services to anyone living in the uk
anymore because
quote it constitutes an infringement of
blizzard's intellectual property rights
and inducement to players of blizzard's
games
to breach their agreements with blizzard
end quote to be clear it's not confirmed
that this is the strategy that
activision blizzard is going to use in
this case
but it's worth noting that it's worked
for them in the past now i'm not here to
compare which game is a worst cheating
problem but cheating in warzone has
gotten so bad
and so blatant that warzone streamers
like mr gold after boasting about how
good they are at the game
got caught using cheats mid stream
just because i have a good recoil i'm
good at the game is it the first time
you see someone
good at the game now i'm talking with
you guys because you really
i i i play and i look at the chat and be
like
what's going on and yes that [ __ ]
quickly had his twitch channel deleted
at this point we don't know much more
about the lawsuit but
thanks to the discord statement that the
cheating website made
we do know that they've essentially shut
everything down
and stopped offering their services
which a lot of customers
are pissed about now is this lawsuit
gonna stop people from cheating in war
zone
hell no but it's definitely a step in
the right direction
and we recently got the announcement for
the next game in the franchise call of
duty cold war
we now know that warzone is going to be
a part of the call of duty franchise
moving forward
and receiving updates throughout the
game's life cycle and this puts
activision blizzard in a fantastic
position
you have an incredibly popular battle
royale that millions of people are
playing on twitch
and you're gonna have an influx of
millions of new players when this new
game comes out
so if there was ever a time to try to
get a handle on this cheating problem
it would be right now it is it is so
difficult with this cheating issue for
me to delineate whether or not like
i'm just [ __ ] or i'm just getting like
[ __ ] by cheaters because i think it's
a bit of both i'm not bad at the game
you